trey lance pro day two
yesterday more and more of the top
quarterbacks having a second pro day
because they can't have private workouts
due to the pandemic lance could go as
high as
three in theory yeah although even
though he was the betting favorite at
one point to be the third overall pick
he's
he's not now four i think is his ceiling
to the falcons or someone who would
trade up right do you agree i would
agree
i would yeah i mean you know listen they
kyle shanahan the 49ers they were there
yesterday
i'm sure they're still tossing around
the idea trey lance i mean
trey lance has a lot to like you know
he's got some legit legit
elite traits his arm is really powerful
his running is special
it is but he hasn't played football in a
long time mike
and even within that like we talked
about you know
he didn't have to ever really carry the
team or be the focal point of the team
or have a two-minute drill mike i mean
he's never had a two-minute drill
in college you know that i mean he's
never had that wow so
those are the things again i love the
talent but scare me
and then here's another aspect too mike
that i think people are talking about
so wait you're gonna get trey lance
you're gonna draft him at four
and then what put him behind matt ryan
and then he's not gonna play football
for another year
you know to me that i i don't i don't
that doesn't
sound like a number four pick to me i
love his talent i just think there's
things that scare me a little bit
and that's why i wouldn't quite pick him
there peter king pointed out yesterday
in football night in america that arthur
blank the owner of the falcons is
fascinated by this class of quarterbacks
and
it was 13 years ago when the falcons
were torn between matt ryan
and glenn dorsey who ended up not living
up to the potential of a five
top five pick he played his fifth
overall to the chiefs that year but
blank wanted new quarterback new phase
the franchise they were recovering from
the mike vic fiasco
and it worked out well with matt ryan
and the thing is for the falcons
you're not going to be in this spot very
often i know where you get
one of the top quarterbacks they could
always trade up like they did they
traded way up to get julio jones in
2011.
but that's got to be part of this
analysis
do you go with a guy who then would
develop quietly for a year or two
and then become your quarterback and it
may just be one year we talked about
matt number next year and after this
year
i think you make the decision remove the
band-aid
and move on or or renew your vows with
matt ryan and keep him around for five
more years
i don't think there is a kick that can
continue under the current contract in
2022.
no i'm with you and i will say and again
it's not like
it's not always easy to say this but i'm
a little bit right now in the arrow
we're in
with as many quarterbacks as we see in a
year-to-year basis
there's movement and free agency like i
would start to tend to like
st i wouldn't be thinking about two or
three years down the road anymore with
quarterbacks i would not i think that's
gone
i think that was kind of an old-school
thought like you're gonna draft one of
four
throw them in there get them playing
they need to play you know so
that that would be my my thought on that
a little bit but elena's really
interesting they really are
because i mean mike what do you do i
mean yeah there's a talented guy you
could take him in four
have a quarterback for two years from
now or do you take a guy like kyle pitts
and go
wait mess around with these weapons we
got on offense now
and see where it goes from there it's
it's a it's a tough decision no doubt
what would you do
if you get i mean it's a tough call
because if you get the great quarterback
the position is settled
for 13 or more years like it was with
matt ryan so you got to do your
evaluation if you believe in that guy
then i think you got to take that guy
even if it creates an awkward transition
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports